Trey my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
He's uh,
he's like you said,
he's a straight up and figure it out.
What's going on with that?
Because I saw he posted on
Instagram that he's in big bear.
He's in big bear with his family
and just enjoying the snow.
Oh,
just chilling.
He's our trainer.
I thought he was going up there to train.
I thought it was on.
Got a hopeful you don't
have that I know of.
Not that I know of,
but you know what they're trying to do.
What they're trying to do.
Aldo and Norma Madoff
for a fucking interim.
One 55 and I'm like how do you
have a one 55 interim when Connor?
Just one the one 55 a week ago.
What about Max though?
What about Max Holloway?
He and Max Holloway.
Well he's the got the intern one 45 such
a shit show and Holloway interim cause
all over Nigga Murdoch is sick.
Sick.
Yeah.
That's a great fight.
Although versus,
well,
especially when you see what,
what happened with Michael Johnson.
Michael Johnson stunned Habib,
you know,
he stung him.
He hit him and stunned them.
And Michael Johnson,
with all due respect,
is nowhere near the striker
that Josie Aldo is Jada,
Josie,
all those on a totally different level,
Josie is as powerful as Johnson exposes
the question because he's not as big.
He's been fighting at one 45 his whole
career and he's going to be fighting a
fucking go.
Rilla mean they ain't no rushing go.
Really the difference between Johnson's
bottom game and all those bottom 100%
100% all those will be way better ways.
So all those kicks there a
giant factor because if you,
if all though who has
amazing takedown defense,
fucking amazing,
some of the best take down defense.
So he's also gotten
fucking nasty lick kicks.
So if number come in off moves at him.
What is this?
Who is this?
Will you show me here how beam number
coming off slams UFC for lying to the fans
about Josie?
Aldo demands relevant fight against her.
Why is he saying he's lying to the fans?
Let's see.
Let's see what he says here.
I'll come back on this.
This God damn screen dude.
Uh,
it's clear to everyone that
you hiding Connor from me,
but stop lying to your fans.
Like I don't want fight with Aldo.
I'm ready to fight with
anyone in my division.
Give me relevant fight so
you won't preserve all.
Take your phone away from
your sister cause somebody,
somebody got this phone then making no,
he's definitely doing it.
Do you think he's right in broke
even though she's sell routes,
but I love it.
It makes it more gangster.
Okay.
You've never matched up.
What does it,
I can't see that Jamie,
this thing is in front of it.
Oh,
he never matched up two guys with
the nine and eight win streak in UFC.
Never in UFC history.
Oh,
okay.
That doesn't mean anything.
See,
here's the problem is too expensive.
I see what he's saying,
but let me explain why he's wrong.
They need big relevant
fights to sell paper views.
Right?
And that's all they care about.
Here's the deal.
The UFC was purchased for $4 billion.
Bill,
imagine if you bought a,
I mean you have,
you own a place,
right?
You own your house.
You know what a mortgages,
mortgages are pretty conti.
You'll look at them every month.
He'd go,
Jesus,
you know now if you have a mortgage for
a nice house and you spend 1 million
bucks as a fucking nut,
you've got to make every month,
man,
you've got to think about it.
You've got to go,
okay,
we've got the mortgage is covered.
All right?
And then you move on
with all the other bills.
Write me about it.
So then June a $4 billion house,
what kind of fucking mortgage and how do
we pay the bills by doing huge fights?
Huge.
So we got to figure some shit out.
Interim,
interim,
everybody in the belt.
The reality is John Jones is suspended
and Jon Jones isn't even the champ right
now.
So when he comes back,
he's not even fighting for a world title
and less he fights for the world title.
So you got to have DC has gotta be healthy
or you got to have John Fight for an
interim because they're just throwing
interims out like they're fucking fliers
that they put on your car when a dude's
trying to like sell car washes and my
brother,
if they don't start getting
these fucking cars selling,
they've got to be another season to
fifth factor is going to be added on.
No,
there's not.
there's not even a CCM [inaudible]
some Brad pitch just to sell papers.
These are some shit up you something Doug.
I don't know what they're going to do.
You know,
who knows if I'll be there for it.
But when you look at,
when you look at like the,
the,
the title picture,
who like that card that
they have in Brooklyn,
I mean that is,
that's a paper view card and it
looks like an fs one car right now.
I'm sure they're going to juice it up.
They'll get more,
but it's going to be a die hard fan.
Pay 60 bucks for that shit.
It's hard.
It's hard to make those cards.
So we,
I think we kind of nailed it when
we were talking about it earlier,
like what guys sell paper views.
I think Woodley's a bigger star
now that he'd be Wonderboy,
but he still wants that a paper,
like Dana and I were
having this conversation.
He's like,
you can't have Nick Diaz.
He goes,
nick and says,
I don't want to fight since 2011 he can't
have him step in and just go right up
to the title and tell.
That's what I said.
I said,
but I want to see it,
and he goes,
I want to see it too.
But you can't.
You can't sell it.
Well you will.
No one's going to take the sports series.
If you give a guy who hasn't won since
2011 or 12 give him a title shot.
People at fancy.
I'm like,
come on Bro.
But I think they missed the boat if they
wanted to make the fucking big money.
It's Nick Diaz versus Conor
McGregor is too big brother.
He's trying to fight at one seven come on.
No,
his [inaudible] his brother
was too big for him.
He's too big,
way too big.
I think that talk is nonsense because
Connor is the one 55 pound champ.
Nate fought at one 55 most of his career.
He fought at one 70 a couple
of times and he's undersized.
Don Young can beat him at one 70 he's a,
he's a legit one 70 or though,
especially Donald,
he's even won 70 maybe,
but he fights one 55 easy look great
against Michael MacDonald at 55 Tyron
Woodley,
if his fucking life depends on it,
Tyron Woodley is not gonna make it 55 so
the naming the champ can't make one 55
at one 70 Nate can.
So Nate is not a real one.
79 here's to your point,
in Dana's point,
he doesn't want to fight since 2011
and you don't have common your cash cow
fight.
This monster hasn't one forever talk.
Great Story.
It really is.
I love it.
Big Brother's steps in cut my,
I would watch it,
I'd watch him in,
but to your,
to your point,
they have to figure something
out to get these stars.
It doesn't matter because
you can't do it overnight.
To me it doesn't matter.
You put Nick Diaz for what
he's done out of respect.
Who's going to complain?
Right.
Well apparently they thought for it.
Nick Diaz,
Robbie Lawler and uh,
nick passed on it.
That's the word.
That's the word behind the scenes.
Interesting.
Maybe I'm not supposed to say that,
but uh,
I wanted to see that fight.
I would love to see that rematch.
But I think nick wants
a fucking title fight.
You know,
I think nick is like,
look,
I want a big,
big name or a title fight.
I love how they make these demands.
Scam money.
Make Nick made some money.
He's not ridiculous.
He doesn't spend it all.
Well,
how about Nate?
I'm not,
I'm not answering the call.
And this is 20 million.
Yeah,
we talked about,
we talked about that
recently in the podcast,
so I was like,
well,
let's break this down because like,
let's say they do a
million pay per view buys,
which is like top end,
right?
There's only a few people
that have ever sold a million.
It's like Brock,
Rhonda Conner sit.
It's okay.
1 million is top of the food chain,
so a million pay per
view buys at 60 bucks.
That's you're taking one
third right off the bat.
For Nate,
it's really hard to justify giving
someone $20 million for something.
I don't do that.
It's going to be real hard and then
obviously on or could demand that Connor's
like one of the only guys that
can get that kind of money.
He's the only one of you guys you think
eventually guys would just start doing,
I think it's so big like Connor,
he just does his own show
and and he gets his own.
People know the EOC.
Lawyers are too good to let
you get out of your contract.
They realize that if,
if Nate had a legit fight with
someone other than Connor,
that was exciting.
The problem is there's no one else in
the division that's got that kind of
marquee value.
55 yeah.
It was no one in the division that has
the kind of marquee value that if you had
a look,
I think Nate is a fucking huge star,
but in less than,
especially now.
I mean,
after he beat Conor,
he's one of the biggest stars outside
of that upper echelon paper view,
like level.
And he's,
but he's not a world
title holder right now.
So if you wanted to really
have a big fight for Nate,
I would have to have him that would work.
Fight all day.
I would work.
That would work
[inaudible].